toujours troisième épisode de la vie du
lycée nous avons bien failli rater le
début il est vrai qu'ici à l'hôtel on
commence demain on est dans notre salle
un étage moi je vais dansant trouvait
donc je me lève à 5h30 pour prendre le
bus etc cet hôtel est un véritable hôtel
avec des chambres de différentes
catégories avec de vrais clients qui
donne un véritable avis ça fait
travailler les enfants et ça nous permet
de séjourner dans des hôtels de qualité
avec un prix tout à fait abordable voilà
et c'est utile la particularité cette
semaine c'est que le professeur n'est
pas un professeur la transmission de la
pratique s'effectue de l'étudiant de
deuxième année à l'étudiante en première
année trek avec le style parfois on a
les mots pour nous c'est vraiment très
simple de la démo très simple mais pour
eux c'est pas facile à comprendre il
s'est aggravé à dire qu'une aussi à un
moment donné m formateur et voilà c'est
ça nous prépare pour la vie future et
pendant ce temps là en cuisine une
première leçon pour les élèves de
seconde je vais donc
ces variantes du ver sont clarifiées
l'arrivée
une certitude le blanc ça colle aux
doigts mais revenons à voter le son une
préparation du plateau du petit déjeuner
est donc en fait c'est très facile qui
suit en fait comme sur la photo qui est
juste derrière donc pour la mise en
place du plateau de petit déjeuner
d'accord je vérifie toujours que la
serviette et bien propre
bonjour madame
side au petit déjeuner je vous
apporterai président jean
leçon 2 a pris le départ des clients la
remise en état de la chambre attention
lit au carré obligatoires le professeur
prend soin du dos de son élève on va zy
prié à genoux pour l'ergonomie c'est
beaucoup mieux pour tango
ok super donc en prime tu peux mexique
un temps où tu vas quand tu fais
[Musique]
à la réception une autre équipe assure
le passage des consignes un peu plus
loin on s'active dans l' agence de
voyages et la boutique de vente à
emporter
c'est là que ne vous entraîneront demain
pour notre dernier épisode